so my name is Jay bomb Jeong and I'm the
kernel developer working at the Wolfram
research and my talk title 3d printing
is basically talking about how to use
the Mathematica I mean the 3d printing
with Mathematica so that's the general
topic of mine
so this is like us three I mean the
general flow of 3d printing the first
step you need to do you need to get some
model so there are various way to get
model into mathematica like access to
repository the the curated data so there
are many data set in Mathematica you can
get clearly and also you can using
import functions to import any 3d data
out there and also you can just create
models in Mathematica with some
mathematical functions after you get
model next step will be the analysis
what I mean is you need to check the
model is actually good enough to print
out and also you can get some get to
know some properties of your mother
people you print like estimated price or
how big it is something like that or so
you for engineer as fact you can so
check if you're researching model has
some some weakness or not after that is
last stages productions actually print
so there are three different way we
categorize away like using the 3d
printer local 3d printing and your home
and also you can send your model to
online printing service or you can just
create the 3d foam it the files like stl
obj so let's get into little details so
sheer stone let made 3d printer models
so this basically is from the
mathematica the data so this first one
who is kind of small it's from anatomy
data so you can use the entity or you
can say anatomy data scar kemal legend
you will get this lizard
okay so let me get to the slide okay and
this one is not data and so we adding
almost every third data that previously
graphics we add a new property called
religion so it's not just discretized
using the discretizing repeat we
actually the fine-tuning back to mesh so
this message they're getting from kumar
legend should be good to print
and here is the chemical data this is
one that we work with an airport so for
example ugh here you can you see
currently if you get just graphics and
do the discretized graphics then you
don't Iraq 3d yeah what so is it you
should be good by me
it should be graphics I miss let me just
opportunities just sometimes too many
all working flatly yes yeah but okay
Molly to flood this and ok let me pass
that So So You molecular blood EP use
that you can get graphic 3d and then you
can apply discretized graphic but that
will not giving the same digit you get
here so this one is fine tune the mesh
region which works well with 3d printing
and here's another one your elevation
data and this is a new type the legend
so it giving you elevation data and this
one is what you see in not right now but
we have some something new this one
where can I just okay so let me worry
about that
hey something's messed up sorry about
this yeah from now
Wow everything's messed up now okay I
just gotta say so dear see you see the
leader a shin is not so great right now
but the coming battle America tomorrow
great yeah so tomorrow you had a much
better resolution of this one this one
looks totally looks like a Mount Everest
but you imagine it really looks like
some mountain and you get much better
the resistant that's good to know so and
then
case something it seems like okay sure
veto and and then there are another data
like solely to data legend this dodging
giving actual the mesh region but it
giving some function what I mean is you
can apply the parameters here and then
this create a legend that you get
actually do so it's slightly different
type of legend but also you can see some
printable data let me see what I don't
know why is crashing
okay it's broken in some sense I should
I have some bad color right now so that
is the owner you Jennifer so share we
honor the way so in putting 3d models so
this is subtitle 3d graphic type format
sta TI y obj and this is look same old
one but in new version what we improve
the pokemon service to an obj 3d
important functions so for example like
if you see one of the marketing page
meters so this is time comparison
support large image it improved like 100
more than hundred times faster than
before that's what we have in new
version of america and other ways using
3d the 3d platformer chance so what you
see is in general if you just print out
for example like a risotto plotting NC
so this is what you see if you see it
you see the stop is actually seen paper
paper seen so in this case if you just
try to print this original the print
what is not the graphics it doesn't
really work well because it's just seen
anything so we adding some new flooding
called like ticks office what it does is
it actually giving thing is
automatically to your flat so you can
now it's a printable model here and
another languages
okay she remarks so another the plot
team we have here is fields office what
it does is actually just making pattern
base so it also making the printer
functions so if you remove this one you
will see it's also pivoting and if you
plug in this to printer than printer
will complain it about it let me just
check on which one though it test this
is a flat import the 3d plot so it only
works is the plat function and algorithm
can generate 3d model what dodgy mean is
you know you applying second sequence of
functions mess with functions and then
create some 3d printable object for
example we have image and then you do
some image processing colony get it just
changing black to white white black
after that we have function for the
image mesh which actually converting the
image to mesh and we do operation legend
product with line so this is actually
extrusion but usually if you have to the
extrusion with just graphic it will not
it is not that easy you have to do so
many many computation but here's just
legend product it makes sense you know
image with line today giving kind of
cylinder shape 3d shape here and this
definitely printable
in here yeah you can see easily so
oops
let me see oh yeah I didn't evaluate
this one so that's why sorry
so it's triangle with NOC and then dot
actual this part is the rectangle so its
mix of triangle rectangle in this case
okay where I am
okay here we go and another thing after
you get the model you want to do some
analysis so here's some basic example
doing analysis so you get a model from
example data the famous Space Shuttle
after that you can easily compute the
volume of this region and then so you
get the density of aluminum this is
possible because we now have like we
from hyper access an entity and then
compute the area and estimate some price
so this is just simply example two
syllable pressure you can do with mesh
and now so to find out the meshes
actually the good mesh to print out we
have a new function called fine mesh
best best effect and then the power mesh
so this is list of defect you can find
with Mathematica so we kind of
categorize some some popular defect
popular thousand years sounds good but
here we have a chi detection and T
Junction over epic faces dangling edges
and singular bodies is flipping
francisco's etc so you said you all this
is very easy ok let me see so you just
do fine it comes out I don't know so
basically just fine damaged effect and
then put a mess and it giving try to
detect every defect that I just show you
and then visualize it so flipping faces
four edges is all highlighted and easily
you can see what effect you have and
other one other usages like you can
specify specific defect so hold a G then
it only show you the whole
highlighting or if you want to get the
cell you can using the second argument
sell this means you actually get the
depicted cell in this case this whole
123456 on the water once you find the
fact you can now deliver it so again
just use the permission plug into your
mesh then you can find you can type your
mesh and then if you want to just remove
one defect you can specify also then you
see there's still detect here only the
isolate isolated body this is removed
and thatís another operation you can do
using those new function share legend
what it does is so you have some solid
and it slowly determines if you print
sending that to printer you see this
slice is all peeled and such most of
cases you don't want to field it require
more material and visually it doesn't
really make any difference and she'll
legend actually how old are your model
so you got some empty inside and then if
you see this slice is that the middle
part is empty so you can reduce the
amount of material you use and if you
check the pole you move it it's more
than half reduce more than half and
here's on some other example you can do
with the mathematica so you have a model
and this is function we using the
antitype fpm finite element element
package and this is some operation that
actually compute the stress of your
mother and you know you got some per
meter you need to plug into the
functions using the optimal path and you
do any side with these tracks and then
there are another function inside that
actually the showing the stress you just
completed by this one
and so people you print you can check
the weakness of your mother so this is
star like what happened inside of the
print of 3d let me brief mention so let
me see so we first thing happen in the
mathematica it discretize it so we piss
graphics 3d unity discs ties or main
lead and instead to find that effect and
then repair you need to have some
reasonable dinesh region after that as
you know if fine dapat and then if you
find actual defected it try to repair it
after the pair we send into printer but
people I didn't put that step of people
you send printer there are other
operation like a resizing if your mother
is too small or too ROG then it
automatically sizing to decent size
that's one thing we do and also if you
specify some unit it also do some
conversion based on your yo given data
and at the end it keeping the nice
summary let me see some examples here so
for example this one if you don't
specify anything ed open your it is oops
send your model to you tip off river in
my case I setting my default free beer
as some porn app dr. here so this is
what what you see
and you can also specify people to
prettier if you want using like a
MakerBot so in this is exam probably
calling the MakerBot so for example like
now is open up with makeup on and
another way you start like a sending it
to file so you get such a simple same
thing model and you specify the filename
with corresponding the STA in this case
you create one to create stl file and if
you see the summary status its
successful let me just try it and also
we here report if you see is showing
every process is ok so it describes a
sex play no defect scaling and then
export and the last one I you show share
is like sending to online printing
service so why Todd is still estas unum
Prince ops with support so I met her
lies copy of shape waves with your homes
so what I thought is same thing
discretize defect and then now is
sending into online printing service so
inside of it we even natural sending to
each online service have deep different
requirement even the file type they stop
what are different so we pure for jump
like specify Scorpio we check their spec
and combat GDP necessary converted to
you know southern format and also each
hobbies have different unit so
corresponding to that we you know make
change your model two millimeter
centimeter or whatever you need it so
this is one example so it sending it to
Scorpio kind of
pensive and then you just check and then
if you press leave you and check out
them you can buy they resent it to you
so this is how the print of 3d works in
Mathematica so it go Liz to make EG to
print so even you don't know anything
about it you just plug in model into
print of 3d then it will automatically
work I mean I don't say is it the end
because you use to its ongoing project
and there are still some room to improve
and that's what we are working on next
version next coming version it will be
better than now and there is other talk
putting up your message from everywhere
is tomorrow and these are you talking
about more like a discrete eigen process
so it does we'll be good also we have
game engine talk tomorrow which will
introduce some unity integration not
integration using Mathematica to make
some game don't write that so if you
interested in is friday for 30 25 so
this end of my talk we have one minute
if you have any question